not to Russell Peters slamming Trevor
Noah for stealing his jokes now we gotta
set this up right okay Russell first
said that this a few years ago after
Trevor got the Daily Show gig yes that
was my I was like wait a minute
yeah he called and they talked about and
Russell decided he didn't want to take
it further publicly so they decided to
have this Twitter exchange and pass it
off as a joke Russell tweeted at Trevor
oh my god I can't believe how gullible
the media are next time I'll choose a
less awkward time to prank you people
watch a Singaporean TV yeah then Trevor
replied you just cost me the president's
presidency of South Africa lol see you
in Vegas
revenge is sweet hash like somebody
gonna get hurt real bad he's gonna get
hurt while now Russell is emitting he
really is mad at Trevor let's first show
you the joke that Russell says Trevor
stole it
here it is I like listening to people
speak Russian you ever heard people
speak Russian it's amazing they just
sound like they're talking backwards the
whole time Vladimir is Babu Steve it got
nasty vodka estimate an average estimate
that they've given about God not a PSP
ma forget what
but words never get used among them near
black sounds like it could have stole
that joke so here's Russell and sways
University other day when sway happens
to be listing his favorite comedians and
mentions Trevor
so Russell brings up the joke stealing
including the one you just saw I'm a fan
of you I'm a Trevor Noah fan why if
you're fan of me own don't need to be a
fan of Trevor no Trouble Man
where what did you accuse it what he
took your material well I called him out
on a once before and then I thought he
would stop and it continued wow your
material yeah so Trevor Noah
I never I've been watching Trevor okay
then watch watch him do his Russian bit
versus me doing my Russian bit and I
could tell you exactly when and why I
wrote this dog I called him out before
when he stole something else and then he
tried to backpedal into him when I
called him he said which joke did I
steal how many jokes he's told you guys
say which one it makes a really good
point
but even that part of damn versus you
know Trevor said which jokes I steal
well you'd be asking terminó officer
tells a lot of jokes you'd have to ask
which one this is not saying which one
of all the jokes I stole from here
you're asking me about Russell the same
but there's a lot of similarities
depression jokes Lee there's
similarities yeah do you really think
that Trevor Noah yes Russell Peters joke
inside that guy watching those two it's
very similar the concept is very similar
you know what I think Russell Peters is
one of the best comedians
there now let's tell you story when we
first medical you should be a comedian
he brings out this little pamphlet he
goes yeah I'm trying I'm trying I got to
see him and it was like 10 of us big
audience and he's so brilliant what he
does he has the ability to create a new
type of comedy yeah and you know yeah
old the some of the International comedy
he does for a lot of different ethnic
groups but watching that I agree he
didn't yield his joke a blessing says
he's reaching he's being petty and
annoying he's she's team Trevor ah she
says they're reaching yeah something
else is No
Chantal says he definitely jacked that
joke Valeska says Russell thinks she's
the only one who thinks Russian sounds
weird let's think people do a lot of
Russian he takes the record it goes
backwards backwards but I mean so
watching late night yeah I think I was
trying to remember what it was but it
was milania's coat that I really don't
care do you cope if you watch I watched
a few late-night to pull some clips for
the show right and I came over who was
but like three of them basically told
the same joke okay yeah all on the same
they're all doing on the same day so you
know they didn't steal for each other
but that's thing like certain topics
there's only so many jokes what can you
do a Russian joke but happen it sounded
like that Russell was saying it was
pretty much a similar time that it was
happening but if you're gonna do like a
joke about someone's accent sure that's
probably the way you're gonna go I just
seems like Trevor knows a very smart guy
he watches his act he's a very smart guy
I don't think he's sitting around double
James said you do not steal each other's
comedy jokes you don't it's the
Mississippi see it's a sin so if Russell
feels that way and there you see that
similarity then he's probably copying it
but maybe I don't know I just don't feel
like Trevor Noah like he's such an
intelligent community yeah like I
understand
Russell Peter says that interview I'm
gonna come off as bitter yeah I think he
kind of does a little bit like he's so
humble how would you feel about that and
and Trevor got The Daily Show I don't
know if Russell went no that's he said
John who's never interested in The Daily
Show I don't know it just seems like
they're both very successful like let it
go you're saying he's done it multiple
times I
I don't know I don't know I wouldn't let
it go someone's stealing something mine
no good oh wait blessing just says
publicity stunts everyone says it's just
the point